how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe
and if there wasn't already enough hype
behind spider-man 3
and as if everybody wasn't already
showing up for the film
today we add even more to the hype and
one more character reported to show up
in spider-man 3 that everybody has been
wanting for a very long time
and that is matt murdock aka daredevil
and not just any daredevil but charlie
cox's daredevil
it looks like the hashtag save daredevil
by the fans that they've all been
tweeting out has
worked or did it as the rumor behind how
charlie cox's daredevil is returning may
not exactly be what you think but we'll
break down this new report right now but
if you're new be sure to subscribe so
you don't miss out on any of the latest
mcu news and so you can enter this
week's giveaway for a chance to win
a zombie mysterio funko pop so today's
news is coming from
murphy's multiverse.com a site that has
been right about many different reports
rumors and leaks in the past and today
the website
is reporting that charlie cox is going
to be reprising his role as matt murdock
aka daredevil in the mcu in spider-man
3. now they didn't actually comment on
what exactly
charlie cox's daredevil's role is going
to be in the movie
there's obviously a lot that the
character could take on in spider-man 3
but it could be
as little as being peter parker's lawyer
matt murdock although daredevil at night
is a lawyer during the day
now this has been speculated about for
quite some time now
in spider-man fire from home peter was
set up by mysterio
at the end of the film mysterio framed
him and revealed his identity
and thanks to jay jonah jameson he told
the entire world that peter parker was
actually responsible for all of the
chaos and destruction that the
elementals have caused in the world
and he said that peter parker was indeed
the person that killed
him mysterio so the authorities are
going to be after peter parker and they
very well might catch him or peter
parker may turn himself
in at which point peter's going to need
a lawyer now the speculation had
always been it's either going to be
jennifer walters who of course is
she-hulk
or charlie cox's daredevil at least we
hoped it was going to be charlie cox's
daredevil and not a new iteration of
daredevil
now since she-hulk isn't going to begin
filming for quite some time now when
spider-man 3 is going to come out before
hulk it didn't really make sense that
jennifer walters was going to be the
lawyer for peter parker
as far as a logistical standpoint on the
back end of marvel studios reports that
tatyana manslany is going to be she-hulk
have been out for a while now
and even though she's basically denied
these claims everybody still believes
that she's going to be playing jennifer
walters
however it's probably going to be a long
time till we see her on screen
however recently in the past couple of
weeks not even
the rights to daredevil went back to
marvel studios from netflix
they can now use daredevil in the mcu in
the past few weeks the hashtag save
daredevil started blowing up
everywhere now this hashtag was
originally intended for marvel to save
the actual series that we saw on netflix
not to actually take charlie cox's
character and put him in the mcu
although i'm sure absolutely no fans are
going to be disappointed to see
daredevil in the mc with spider-man and
that daredevil be charlie cox
and again given the situation it just
makes perfect sense to see him in
spider-man 3 since peter parker
is going to need some help from a lawyer
but spider-man is also going to need
some help as well
from daredevil now again the report
doesn't say if daredevil is going to be
returning to help spider-man or if it's
just going to be matt murdock helping
him out in court but regardless
this means that daredevil charlie cox's
daredevil is going to be in the mcu
which means even if he doesn't play a
huge role in spider-man 3 he now exists
in the mcu and can play a role in his
own film or other films as daredevil
down the road and it's what everybody
wanted it's charlie cox's daredevil not
a new daredevil not a new actor playing
him but charlie cox's daredevil from the
netflix series
so insanely exciting news today let me
know what you think about this super
exciting news in the comments down below
let me know how excited you are for
charlie cox's daredevil to be returning
in spider-man 3.
leave your thoughts down below don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
so you stay up to date on all the latest
mcu news
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof